détermination et re mobilisation pour la
rentrée politique d'alexandra dublanche
la candidate à la présidence de la
fédération les républicains des yvelines
a organisé une réunion publique avec
comme soutient valérie pécresse
tout un symbole pour la présidente de la
région ile de france
je veux vit aujourd'hui comme une femme
qui passe le témoin à une autre femme
alexandra du blanche parce que mon
soutien c'est pas un soutien contre
quiconque c'est une envie de
renouvellement vous savez se renouveler
se rajeunir se féminiser c'est
absolument indispensable pour les partis
politiques
le renouvellement la ligne suivie par
alexandra dublanche des nouvelles
méthodes comme la consultation des
militants sur leurs attentes par rapport
à la fédération des yvelines et sur
différentes thématiques
nous on pense déjà que la droite ne
pourra que se reconstruire que par le
fond en travaillant sur le fond et sur
les idées en étant force de proposition
en montrant toutes nos différences avec
le pouvoir en place que ce soit sur la
hausse des impôts la hausse des dépenses
publiques
l'autorité de l'état la lutte contre le
terrorisme on reconstruit une ligne il
faut qu'on soit crédible et derrière un
sujet de formation des militants qu'il
faut qu'on fasse on n'a jamais été bon
sur les argumentaires
il faut qu'on soit crédible et qu'on
construise une politique qui soit
équilibrée donc on y prendra toute notre
part si l'adhérent veulent de nous faire
confiance
près de 200 sympathisants ont fait le
déplacement des élus des militants qui
ont la volonté de voir alexandre a dû
blanche à la tête de la fédération
d'abord une vraie idée de rassemblement
au delà
colas au delà des clivages qui
apparaissent aujourd'hui dans l'est
républicain il soit vraiment en
rassembleur de des divers divers
chapelle soit laurent wauquiez valérie
pécresse je soutiens parce que ça leur
met de la jeunesse ça remet énormément
de choses qu'il fallait améliorer et
avec alexandra du blanche
nous avons cette possibilité là pour
participer aux élections internes 13
octobre prochain les militants doivent
renouveler leur adhésion party les
républicains avant le jeudi 13 septembre